- I have a question, when
creating "Mad About You,"
you pulled from your real life, so.
- [Paul] It was the only thing I knew.
- What did your wife
think about that though?
'Cause you've been married for,
is it 30-something years?
- Yes, 33 years.
My wife has no idea what
I do professionally.
So the less, I keep her away...
When the show was on, I would
walk around the house, and no.
(audience laughing)
No, she was great.
She was actually instrumental
in finding Helen Hunt.
We went to a,
my wife and Helen had a mutual friend,
and they had a dinner party.
And this was just when I was
writing the first episode,
and was thinking, you know,
I really didn't know who it would,
I had no actress in mind,
and met Helen, and she was
just funny and smart and just,
you know, just kooky enough
and off-balance enough and smart.
And we left, and I said
to my wife, I said,
"What do you think about her as you?"
She went, "She'd be great."
So she was, she was-
- So she gotta say.
- Yeah, oh yes, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't, (laughs)
I wouldn't have cast somebody really,
if my wife said oh, I hate that person.
But you know, the great thing was
we had so many great writers on the show,
and we'd all sit in the room,
and we'd all share our stories
of what happened at home that night.
So if anything is too
personal, I could always go,
"That was the other
guy's wife, that was...
You would never have said that."
(Kelly laughing)
- That's what songwriters do, by the way,
when you're in a
relationship with someone,
and they're like, (laughs),
Why, people are gonna think I'm like,
"Oh, that was the other
writer on the song.
I would never say that."
- Always have backup
behind ya, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. (laughs)
Throw someone else under the bus. (laughs)